eeuu quiere acabar con la reticencia de
los anti vacunas cerca de 80 millones de
personas aún no se han vacunado contra
el kobe 19 en el país que ahora sufre un
repunte de contagios algo que está
agotando la paciencia del presidente yo
vaivén mi mensaje a los estadounidenses
que aún no están vacunados es igual que
están esperando whiteford
lo que más necesitan ver
hemos hecho las vacunas gratuitas
seguras y convenientes binner la vacuna
ha recibido la aprobación de la f1 y más
de 200 millones de estadounidenses han
recibido al menos una dosis
hemos sido pacientes pero nuestra
paciencia se está agotando para acabar
con los estragos que está causando la
variante de alta el demócrata anunció la
vacunación obligatoria para todos los
empleados del gobierno federal requirió
que las empresas con más de 100
empleados inoculen o hagan pruebas
semanales a su plantilla y que las
corporaciones que trabajan con el estado
inmunicen a todos sus trabajadores los
gobiernos locales también están
implantando normativa al respecto los
ángeles exigirá la vacuna a los
estudiantes mayores de 12 años y es que
la situación del cob y 19 en eeuu sigue
siendo alarmante los casos están
aumentando y las hospitalizaciones y
muertes casi duplican las de la misma
fecha del año pasado desde el ejecutivo
esta crisis sanitaria se achaca a los
que no se han vacunado que suman la
mayoría de los positivos